[Music]
the aquatic ecosystem could give our
food chain a helping hand the demand for
food is rising and more sustainable
production systems are needed that's why
europe is opening up to the algae sector
humans have been eating macroalgae for a
long time but attention is now turning
to their smaller cousins microalgae for
their nutritional potential
the company all microalgae in pattayas
portugal is developing algae-based
applications for foods like cookies
bread snacks and spreads
food engineer annabella raimondo works
for the university of lisbon and helps
develop these microalgae products
[Music]
it is extremely important to find
alternative food sources which are
sustainable and also of nutritional
benefit to people
microalgae are extremely important
ingredients because they are rich in
both protein and bioactive compounds and
therefore they're an extremely important
source of nutrition and can be used in
lots of food
there are thousands of species of algae
living both in fresh water and sea water
larger are called macroalgae and they
make up 20 of all species the remaining
80 is made of microalgae these single
cells begin their journey to become a
source of food in this laboratory in
these flasks that contain a liquid
culture
every micro algae has varying
nutritional value but two of the most
popular for human consumption are
chlorella and spirulina
in this lab we do the analytics that
allow us to evaluate whether the growth
in the photobio reactors is going well
or not we need to know what happens
inside the cell to determine the total
protein value and the magnesium consumed
within the nutrient medium
we also check the iron and several micro
and macro nutrients that are essential
to the culture and that allow the algae
to optimize its nutrient consumption
algal cultivation requires exact
procedures in order to achieve abundant
biomass yields traditional yeast like
the one used to make beer activates the
fermentation process then the culture is
injected into large photobioreactors
where it grows until it reaches the
right quality standard
there is a seed and inoculum that
inoculates another reactor which
contains a larger volume every time we
do this until we have a significant
amount to process the processing is
meant to give us a concentrate of cells
then we can either produce a
concentrated paste for the aquaculture
market for example or we can make a
powder that can be used as an ingredient
or food supplement
the food industry's interest in micro
algae is rising quickly due to new
consumer habits sustainability of
production but also for health reasons
our plant-based protein production will
allow us to go into different dietary
areas not just vegetarian and vegan
there's also very interesting elements
that hasn't yet been developed clinical
and medical food for people who are sick
and who have difficulties eating high
protein products
under the eu's farm to fork strategy the
commission is looking to unlock the full
potential of the algae industry by the
middle of 2022
[Music]